jean luc mélenchon et avec no mercy
jean-luc guette la
dalle est heureux il a l'air fatigué il
a passé une bonne nuit je dors ça ça va
de sava jean-luc
excusez moi y'a quelqu'un qui claquent
des dents à côté de vous
depuis un an on va régler ça jean luc
mais je vous rappelle tout dit alors
c'est voilà alors allez
guerre n'ont jamais vous êtes un
professionnel des habituels présents sur
un plateau donc que ça vous physiquement
ça ne nous atteint pas autant que des
gens qui passent comme moi de temps en
temps d où la charge d'adrénaline est
terrible à faire passer du coup nos
repas avant de 3 heures du matin
simplement parce que la méditation et là
comme je ne prends aucun produit pour
dormir vous avez raison lui en général
recherche eer il m'arriva comme moi ni
pour dormir des pointes réveiller le
problème c'est que voilà jean-luc
jean-luc une chose que vous aviez ce que
vous étiez stresser les jours qui ont
précédé le débat ou bien pas du tout est
ce que vous y avez pensé ce que vous
l'avez boîte
bas ou bien sûr que ça ne serait pas
normal que je n'étais pas stressée et
berciaud j'ai été stressé
mais pas peut-être que maintenant c'est
le bénéfice de l'expérience pas comme
c'était le cas auparavant ou dans
d'autres campagnes que j'ai fait
auparavant campagne mais vous savez il
ya aussi une excitation qui est liée à
l'exercice même de ce qu'on fait moi je
crois que ça j'aime ça ah oui bah a
proposé des arguments café une pensée
après il ya le lard même du débat que
monsieur zemmour faut pas trop lui en
vouloir il le maîtrise pas il était
journaliste polémiste alors il parlait
tout seul
alors vous l'avez fait beaucoup rire
hier on va le voir dans un instant il a
beaucoup rigolé parfois est aujourd'hui
peugeot juste pour revenir à la première
chose les audiences sont incroyables
vous faites des pics à 4,1 millions de
téléspectateurs alors que sur france 2
il ya un million de téléspectateurs à la
même heure est ce que pour vous déjà
c'est une victoire ou est ce que c'est
une fierté parce que ça
vous n'êtes pas qu'un oui oui bah
oui mais bon je vais pas non plus vous
dire que moi j'ai été très surpris de
voir l'article j'ai lu dans le canard
enchaîné qui me traîne dans la boue que
suivant une habitude qui après journal
maintenant parce que le réfère flat est
bon ils ont ramassé où les ragots de des
gens de france 2 qui sont ni discuter
avec nous à une discussion loyal avec
eux on leur a dit gwadar qu'on trouvait
un peu extravagant pas acceptable dans
leur manière de faire monter un ont fait
le le faux-pas fichiers que personne ne
connaît le gard immigrés les baguettes à
l'elysée oui c'est à l'époque quand il
avait fait l'émission jean luc away
parce qu'il y avait des invités donc se
présenter devant jean-luc hees est vrai
que ça s'était pas très bien passé et
que d'après jean-luc il n'avait pas été
très correct c'est ça en lui pas
d'argent
alors quatre morts voilà voilà
shirin la dernière fois je me dis allez
un effort l'heure tourne je vais à
france info alors on me dira chez les
français et alors on sort en garde c'est
en france et les chauffeurs de bus et
les bonzes rapport aux chauffeurs de bus
j'aime bien les chauffeurs de mus comme
demande et puis je me dis oui j'ai déjà
vu celui-là tu parles charles c'était un
militant du front national
candidate front national et c'est déjà
la deuxième ou troisième fois qu'ils le
sortent et dans une émission comme
chauffeur de bus à manille ça c'est pas
des méthodes alors après là il ya plus
de confiance
ils sont allé pleurnicher dans le dans
le plumage du canard pour aller raconter
une vision enfin ils sont trés tourner
sur eux-mêmes ils n'écoutent pas les
eaux alors les intéresse pas qu'il peut
leur dire ça les intéresse pas bon voilà
après hier soir non ils ont moi je suis
pour rien ils ont pris un ils ont pris
une belle tôle
non mais alors que non mais attends hier
soir vous avez regardé ce pour regarder
moi j'ai eu le temps de regarder j'ai
juste des images alors le décor on dira
un crématorium et j'ai vu là c'est un
déport ces temps d un déport un décor
composé alors il ya un truc je leur dis
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de vouloir et
personne n'avait osé leur père est un
personnage était malgré tout alors tout
le monde avait un petit peu comme des
poils autour bon pour ceux qui regardent
attentivement mais ça se corrige pas si
noir non non là le truc là je vais te
dire la vérité jean luc je connais un
peu la télé ça se corrige pas facilement
je crois que ça va être compliqué ce que
là je viens de voir accord le plateau à
venir il faut vite qu'ils trouvent un
endroit pour le stocker parce que je
suis pas sûr que les messieurs
reviennent je veux voir sur ma part on y
arrive cyril vous avez vu le film qui
s'appelle soleil vert
alors les vieux loups vue reste un
endroit où les gens qui ont en marre de
vivre dans un monde pourri ça c'est bon
pour éteindre la lumière alors on les
installe et puis on leur projette des
billets dans les bois et tout ça est la
cinquième symphonie et c'est que c'est
pour ça que c'est ma plus penser à un
crématorium c'est pourquoi ces acquis et
visuellement ce que c'est elise est à
présent elle est jaune valérie pécresse
et mira darmanin il est il a fait sa vie
alors jean-luc on va revenir un peu sur
le débat on à alexis corbière je sais
pas si vous connaissez qui est là sur le
plateau entendu parler
ils seront tous ces bons alexis corbière
qu'il a on a alors on abat ya carla fans
d'eric zemmour 21 ans femme d'affaires
et patriote merci d'être là hugo
politologue qu'on connaît bien ici et on
à louis brouillard étudiants et on va
parler aussi tout à l'heure de l'asthme
et aussi bien sûr people avec voilà ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui dans la
presse autour d'eric zemmour mais je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur le débat on
l'a dit c'est un énorme coup pour bfm tv
franchement tout le monde le voulait ce
débat même mois on va pas se mentir
voilà je voulais absolument organiser le
débat eric zemmour jean luc mélenchon
chaud je tendais par les gens lui
convier la vérité et jean-luc il a été
franc et j'ai donné sa réponse et je
peux la comprendre la réponse de
jean-luc mélenchon tu voulais pas le
faire ici parce que tu disais quoi la
zemmour venait de ses news c'est le même
groupe et que tu disais ils jouent à
domicile c'est ça
la vérité il ya eu beaucoup de
discussions ça m'a fait rigoler parce
que bon j'arrive maintenant quand même à
prendre un peu de détachement avec une
ford aurait dit que j'étais le chalet la
négociation de paix au vietnam dont même
la forme de la table alors les copains
et l acharné à ceux ci à se laver vous
voulez ceci l'autre cela moi j'ai eu ça
mon jeu j'en avais assez donc quand vous
mets proposés on a regardé de race et le
groupe en fait cyril j'avais absolument
rien contre le fait de faire des
missions avec vous je ça aussi je me
laisse franchement à bercy moi je
travaille avec les gens loyaux après ils
sont ce qu'ils sont moi je ne mens pas
contenir les pompes ni compris des
alléluia moyens face et c'est pas ça mon
sujet mon sujet c'est un rapport loyal
parole donnée parole tenez j'ai fait
deux émissions avec vous vous avez
toujours été loyal vous m'avez jamais
tiré les comptes mais vous avez été
loyal dans ce qui était prévu regardez
ya guillaume bigot qui est pas toujours
d'accord avec vous qu'il est la soirée
oui complètement en fait il ya ya on
s'attendait il faut dire la vérité si
rive on s'attendait il y avait une
attente énorme parce qu'on s'attendait
un peu au clasico psg om on s'attendait
pour les gens qui adorent la politique
et j'en fais partie c'est king kong
contre godzilla on s'attendait à ce
qu'il dit sang de la chique et du
mollard et en fait ils ont eu
l'intelligence l'un comme l'autre de
tenir leurs positions assez fermement et
d'élever le débat à un certain niveau de
sorte que ce qu'on nous a présentés
comme la télévision spectacles et comme
une espèce de déferlement irrationnel de
haine populiste de part et d'autre
d'ailleurs a plutôt été comparé à ce
qu'on voit des éléments de langage hyper
formatés totalement formaté avec les
pieds les regrets mais que l'ortie
costard là tout comme ça tous serrés qui
débite leurs éléments marketing
totalement grotesque là on a vu quand
même deux visions de la france qui sont
affrontés avec je pense un certain
niveau retrouvé à la dignité de débats
j'ai trouvé le débat de fond très bon
entre les doigts de son championnat il
ya beaucoup de gens qui m'avait dit
avant le débat vous allez voir ça va
faire pschitt parce qu'on en attend
tellement que vous on va tous être déçu
et j'ai revu le débat avait du niveau je
trouve franchement il y avait du niveau
et je trouve que on n'a pas été déçu il
ya eu d'énormes punchline il s'est passé
des choses s'étaient pas chiant on va
pas se mentir à un moment moi je me suis
dit on va être déçu mais non je trouve
que ça ça a tenu ses promesses je peux
ajouter antoinino parce que en fait
finalement on est d'accord qu'il ya
quand même une montée de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la radicalité jean luc
mélenchon un discours radical eric
zemmour un discours radical sandrine
rousseau qui est sorti avec les écolos
un discours radical et c est cette
radicalité il ya une façon de le dire
qui est bas plus le niveau baisse plus
le ton monte en fait plomb que le son
est plus les gens vont s'agresser
culture du clash réseaux sociaux etc moi
j'ai une autre lecture de ça je pense
qu'à partir du moment où la classe
dirigeante qui nous gouverne depuis 40
ans qui fait absolument n'importe qui en
permanence dit il est interdit d'avoir
un mot plus haut que l'autre
effectivement ça fait comme une cocotte
minute et à mon avis la pression elle
ressort et l'intérêt de jean luc
mélenchon comme d'eric zemmour c'est
d'articuler ça avec un discours cohérent
et argumenté alors jean luc mélenchon
j'aime bien ce qu'il y à dndi parce que
c'est vrai que la télévision dans un
premier temps à tuer tout ce qui est l
art oratoire exactement que quand vous
êtes en gros plan la moindre déformation
du visage amplifie le discours d'une
manière qui peut paraître très agressive
à celui qui regarde parce que on vous
voit de très près dans là tu passes je
passe très bien l'agent l'urgence est
conscient
deuxième chose
c'est que vous vous en ai pas peut-être
rendu compte mais pour lui comme pour
moi le débat était d'une totale dureté
parce que nous sommes deux visions du
monde extrêmement outre 8 si vous voulez
on ce n'était pas en train de faire
semblant ça monte ça va lui et moi nous
sommes depuis deux siècles sur deux
collines face à face un jour d'aller lui
le vie je pense qu il le vivait parce
que lorsque vous vous avez changé lui
devrait changer ça la différence alors
justement jean luc mélenchon et et eric
des mots je le dis on veut pas de
politique ici mais je vous ai trouvé en
tout cas sincère les deux jeunes et
trouver premier set au sein certes c'est
ce qu'il va dire c'est vrai deux visions
du monde mais les deux il croit à fond
les deux sont persuadés qu'ils sont dans
le vrai les deux la défendent et c'est
vrai qu'on les a sentis plutôt sincère
est ce que
jean luc est ce que vous êtes trouvé bon
hier
j'ai incapables de nous évaluer pour
dire que je ne le fais jamais joué dans
les amis alors il vous en dit quoi vos
ailleurs je ne non mais et vous en dit
quoi vos amis courageux ils étaient très
contents parce que si vous voulez pour
vous il y avait deux objectifs un bon
chien le site rappelle aussi un souvenir
et on a une équipe qui a entraîné à
réfléchir comme vous êtes à la troisième
campagne présidentielle et que vous avez
autour de vous des gens qui ont pour la
plupart moins de 40 ans il ya aussi
complices et certains appellent 30 il ya
une vitalité absolument gigantesque qui
se dégage de tout ça et c'est eux qui
s'amusent à précilhon des angles de
regard sur la vie qui sont très
différents des miens parce que
finalement moi je vis un peu confiné
certaine manière les rapports des gens
avec moi sous fossé va pas mettre le nez
dehors donc je vais vous de mal à
remplir ma fonction principale de
politique celle qui m'a toujours fasciné
comme intellectuel c'est cher l'eponge
mais sans lui d'entrée puis bojan l'une
vote vote votre entourage vous ont dit
que vous aviez gagné le débat pont pour
alexis corbière il a gagné le débat hier
face à me eric zemmour parce qu on dise
où il ya un gagnant dans un débat sont
en dise voilà c'est lui moi je me
rappelle
cyril écouter
jean luc agent lui aussi jean luc je te
jure regarde moi je vais je vais te
donner des exemples quant à l'époque je
te le dis le à chaque fois le débat
ségolène sarko je suis sorti j'ai dit ça
y est ségolène c'est fini le débat
hollande sarko je suis sortie du débat
qui a lui jugé sur la tv moi j'ai dit
moi j'ai dit j'ai dit l'exacte mary mc
on savait que c'était cuit pour la pour
jean marie le pen au civil si vous
voulez lire écouter mois une petite
seconde je suis ma détresse et moi c'est
là pour ça
je voudrais plaidé un autre point de vue
ne fait pas ça si tout est ramené à un
mac alors il ya plus d'échangés
intellectuels possible comme on dit
j'avais compris que lui n'avait perdu
l'autre et c'est dans ce pays c'est
incroyable tout le monde est devenu un
expert en communication et du coup ça tu
me sens de ce qui est dit parce que
ségolène royal a commis des erreurs
c'est certain dans le débat est là elle
n'a pas su mener ce match mais elle dit
elle a dit beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes et tout ça a été tué par
le fait que bon c'est le cas ils main et
ma mère ne le pen moi je peux pas vous
dire si elle a dit des choses
intéressante elle nous à faire dès
qu'elle ouvre la bouche pour
s'y lancer
mais vous comprenez ne réduisons pas à
des matches et sait on dira cette fois
regardé hier soir et un coup de fraport
bien sûr qu'on ait deux sur deux
collines depuis 200 ans mais tourner en
rond je veux dire à part répété qu'il
faut jeter les immigrés dans ses vols
intérieurs d'air mais c'est tout ce
qu'il avait à dire et cela michelin
michelin l'islam sauter en rond et dès
qu'on arrivait sur un autre sujet
fallait qu'ils ramènent l'islam et puis
des fois quand il le faisait pas ces
voix qui l'armée d'entamer la rue alors
y avait plein de choses il ira c'est
vrai qu'on pourrait revenir sur le débat
pendant encore beaucoup de temps je veux
montrer différents extraits déjà il ya
un truc que j'ai remarqué moi c'est que
jean luc mélenchon avait plein de choses
sur sa table et eric zemmour justin
vernon jean luc mélenchon je croyais
qu'elle allait contrôler l'histoire des
débats très attendu c'est comme ça qu'on
veut dire à maxime à suivre en simultané
sur rmc vous pouvez réagir en direct ya
un style c'est vrai on laisse en fait on
dit au début pour pour vous d'abord j'ai
demandé à alexis corbière vous l'avez
trouvé bon jean luc ouimet légende jean
luc où l'opinion qu'a été donné ta c'est
juste ce qu'il incarne jean luc c'est
une pensée une pensée la pensée
républicaine du partage des partageux
qui pensent que la crise écologique est
quelque chose de crise mondiale et qu en
france où trouver des réponses et
l'autre en face c'est un autre type de
pont c'est pourquoi jean luc il dit
depuis deux siècles qui lorsque la
révolution française a eu lieu il ya eu
aussi des pensées qu'on appelait
contre-révolutionnaires qui pensent que
la souveraineté du peuple c'est pas
possible qu'ils pensent que d'abord les
hommes sont liés à au sol une terre et
qu'on ne peut pas faire nation avec des
idées j'en égaux en droit et c'était
accélère et se débat dure depuis deux
cents ans zemmour c'est le champion de
cette idée mais le l'idée que finalement
tu es français et quand tu es musulman
tu peux pas être en france et d'ailleurs
et mon latin tard le débat non non non
mais ça pourtant
c'est faux archi faux il alors
parce que c'est marrant à l'édile a dit
le contraire hier un grand tournoi
justement fils et déballonner hier parce
que quand il dit au journal pouvez-vous
dire une chose qu'ils sont écoutés
laissez moi ça y est le tuc anti du
journal causeur à quelques mois les
musulmans devront choisir entre la
france et l'islam hier il n'a pas à
assumer quand il a des vrilles et l'a
remis graciant d'ouvriers de mélenchon
lui a dit l'art migration niary tally ah
non c'est pas mon opinion parce qu'il
sait des lois alors on vous ne pouvez
pas dire une chose et son contraire dans
ses
attentes et pardon j'ai pas le progrès
non c'est seymour qui dit une chose et
son contraire non monsieur nez de me
dire être leader maximo vous à dire 2010
un ca en 2010 avait donné je vous donne
était en voile si on mettait les femmes
kim est envoyé aux énigmes attise avec
les beaux jours arrivent sur cette ligne
c'est pas d'autre mot
ces accords en 2007 jonathan cheechoo
blesse open moi qui le dit c'est jean
luc mélenchon j'aimerais qu'on va
changer d'avis qui n'a pas changé reste
courage héroïque sur le débat convoi
n'est que vous la question regardez
regardez série l'attendait c'est
important c'est qu'on m'a aidé parce que
d'hier soir je pense que jean luc il a
marqué le point sur ce que je viens de
dire terre que zemma mais n'a pas assumé
oui devant mélenchon des propos qu'il
tenait en plateau et je vais te dire
j'en ai parlé après avec jean-luc ça
rendait le débat compliqué avec jean-luc
sais que tu boxes avec un type qui s'est
vite en vérité qui dit des provocations
en dix ans les musulmans doivent prendre
doivent choisir dramont ses lisières
meilleures idées non je n'ai pas dit
cela donc jean luc serre a piqué et
pourquoi il avait des notes sans doute
jean luc sur sur cet homme c'est que
jean lui qui vient sérieusement avec 1
il a bossé et l'autre en face il est
celle à qui est fan et kiffa d'eric
zemmour vous avez 21 ans oui vous êtes
fan absolu d'eric zemmour fan absolu
c'est un bien grand mot mais en tout cas
oui je suis partisane de deux sont liés
de le jamais trouvé bon hier j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé très bon j'ai trouvé très
bon c'était pas un exercice facile ya
beaucoup de sujets dans lesquels il
n'est pas enfin c'est pas ses sujets de
prédilection et je les trouvais quand
même assez bon sur tout ce qui était
énergique ce terrain alors ils se sont
attaqués pas mal de fois dans la soirée
regardez vous a fait une petite compil
aqua perton son temps à discuter
du solide monsieur zemmour effet déjà le
perroquet de ce que je dis j'ai rien dit
encore donc ne me prêtez pas des choses
que je n'ai pas dit ce risque avant de
parler vous êtes en danger à mes yeux
vous êtes en danger pour notre pays vous
attend ainsi vous avez été condamné pour
ça donc dong wei vous dit qu'il a marre
de quoi vous commencez de l'interview je
veux simplement que le conseil ne fait
pas le professeur dans domaine que vous
connaissez tous les maux nouvel arrière
vous avez une vision de l'islam qui est
haché
presque il me fait sourire parce que
visiblement vous n'y connaissez rien bah
voyons non vous n'y connaissez rien et
et jean luc mélenchon aussi à donner
plein de surnoms à eric zemmour toute la
soirée la parité de lui donner des
petits surnoms c'était voulu ça nous
paraît développer coeur woody woodpecker
ça on va les voir regarder on va les
voir vous avez vous dira prêt à regarder
ta la république fédérale à écouter ça
va quoi bas supporter coiffé tpao 10
août békaa tous les cinq minutes dès que
je dis un mot là vous êtes là à taper
sur le dos sur le tronc alors monsieur
l'intelligent que se passe-t-il si un
jour si un jour il y avait un problème
et bien ce jour là qu'est ce que vous
avez prévu grands cerveaux pour faire
face à ces missions d'enrayer 2005 elle
serait écoutée petit bonhomme dans l'obs
traité de 2005 est grande et notamment
au tibia et notamment le traité de
maastricht
non ça m'énerve pas sûr c'est très drôle
et puis mais l'enfant est connu pour
être un grand humoriste sur internet
donc en même temps
moi j'aimerais a posé une question à
l'essai avec plaisir j'aimerais savoir
si la paix de glion pédagogie d'eric
zemmour était assez bonne et qu'en
relisant vous n'êtes vous avez appris
des choses
quand même toujours des autres toujours
j'avais sous-estimé déjà à verchères
jamais je me dis ivoirien avait
déboursé une machine bien huilée là un
argumentaire il est dans un cadre et
lecture elle est philosophique si bien
que hier soir si vous voulez j'ai
regardé les choses j'ai appris des
choses je lui dirai pas lesquels de même
que sur les papiers et leurs actes parce
que bien au scrutin il ya un système du
débat et la polémique comme celle là la
communication ultra langagière la
manière de faire en poussant sa commune
i pas quoi mais hier ce qui m'a pardon
je vais peut-être là vous vous lassez
mais pour moi le véritable enjeu il
était jusqu'à quelques mois il va
assumer ce qu'il est et ce qu'il a à
dire et pour vous et rouge à passion
envers me donne le coin comme comme
designer and le poids est ce que les
élections à deux minutes et
directement sim accumuler sur des poids
sur lesquelles on voulait faire reculer
il a été obligé de passer sous la table
à propos de l'arrêt migration incapable
d'expliquer en quoi ça consiste et parce
que la déportation de 5 millions de
personnes c'est quelque chose il a été
obligé sur les femmes de passer dans une
contradiction incroyable cet homme qui
explique qu'elles ont un cerveau
archaïque et que
l elles sont la proie et le butin des
sommes en train d'expliquer que vous ne
savent pas dans les cités choisi enfin
le pauvre était et puis à un moment
donné il a tellement perdu pied qu'il
comptait légende à des noms étrangers
mais juniel vous vouliez comment
maintenant j'ai vu qu'il me dit
étrangers alors on était au séjour dans
des tailles étaient en prison mais il
fait compter comme étrangers de ce que
vous décrivez là jean luc vous vous êtes
le gagnant du débat mais derrière vous
êtes en train de nous déclare que vous
avez gardé banias sur lui
non moi je ne dis pas je fais pas des
matchs n'étaient pas
il avait des choses il a convaincu ses à
venir car il a regroupé les gens qui
croient comme lui il est sur un seul
thème parce qu'il l'a déchiré le reste
ne m'intéresse pas justement le fou de
la faire car la dca la caraïbe son but
donner 12 quel est son but si oui c'est
vrai adam le maire bon il veut siphonner
madame le pen hier soir il a réussi à
siphonner madame le pen il veut
siphonner la plus réactionnaire de l'est
républicain hier soir il est arrivé il a
passé but jean lüthi et moi les miens
qui est de redonner courage ou bien de
dire on n'a pas perdu on se bat et
visions du monde et donc la france nous
notre intérêt c'est de l'art politisée
de la ramener dans le jeu médiatique
partie la
clientèle et chant clientèle bail alors
c'est bye à votre prénom c'est belle et
carla c'est un prénom composé pas
d'accord excusez moi donc bannière car
là
pour vous est ce que jean luc mélenchon
et guillaume bigot je vais te poses la
question tout le monde a fait un cadeau
à eric zemmour en acceptant de débattre
avec lui parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui disent ah parce que jean luc
mélenchon troisième fois candidat à la
présidentielle illégitime
eric zemmour alors qu'il existe pour
l'instant il n'est même pas candidat
pour l'instant il il est pas a déclaré
qu'on dirait ce qui lui offre un cadeau
c'est ou c'était gagnant gagnant mais
moi en fait ce que je comprends pas
c'est qu'il dit que c'était pas un match
mais quand même sur les réseaux sociaux
monsieur mélenchon vous en avez beaucoup
joué avec le tout le tweet qui m'a un
peu choqué vous parliez de soulever eric
zemmour plus le tictoc l'espèce de
montage ou quand vous êtes au bar vous
pouvez un jour là s'ils voulaient pas le
voir garder on regarde
dans la
cour
et
surtout le tout ça c'est assez drôle via
le twitter et dit qu'il va le soulever
donc la soirée ccc sexuelle c'est
lassant la boad la chasse et non mais
voilà non mais d'abord le le le tictoc
j'espère qu'ils vont tous où les
lyonnais
alors jeunes filles en bas le dock est
drôle je suis entouré d'une d'une équipe
de gens qui aiment bien mais de moore
après le plus dont vous parlez je jeu
c'est parce qu'il adore après tout il ya
été un pouvoir hier soir mais j'étais
pas derrière ne peut pas être partout à
la fois donc une honte une témoin j'ai
été traitée hier soir là bas et esma le
gibbon ce soir ici tu es tu étais pas
prêt c'est la vie d'innocents la
question était prévu moi franchement il
n'était pas du tout à égalité parce
qu'on a un candidat déclaré qui est
quand même un homme politique du système
ce que le général de gaulle appelait les
politiciens c'est avec les gens qui vont
être élus pour être élu et qui sont dans
le circuit
je reconnais quand vous êtes causer des
arguments justes mais on peut pas dire
que vous n'êtes pas un homme politique
professionnelle au moins assumée ça et
c'est pas une honte d'ailleurs j'ai pas
du tout une honte non mais passablement
c'est satan c'est pas moi glisse et le
général de gaulle at-on m
je
termine non mais non pas tout à fait
parce que
les partis non mais et donc je reviens
je revis argumentation tout simplement
pour vous dire que la sonaca
implantation on a quelqu'un de chine
sénateurs qui est député et ministre de
plusieurs gouvernements qui dans le
circuit politique depuis 90 ans
d'attenté depuis 30 ans et il fait le
même score que quelqu'un qui est
essayiste et qui n'est pas encore dans
le dernier sondage de son égalité si
vous me demandez qui a fait un cadeau à
qui et dans quel sens pour moi je pense
que à partir du moment où eric zemmour
ne sait pas encore mais comme a dit
christine kelly l'a mis son clignotant
mais il n'a pas tourné n'est pas
officiellement candidat il ne peut pas
être si votre école dont la posture cmn
même hôtel on les rôles embrasse tous
elle il ne peut pas encore être dans la
posture d'un candidat qui fait des
propositions en face jean luc mélenchon
est un professionnel de l'état donc
effectivement voilà on peut se dire que
il était plutôt à égalité alors même
qu'à une inégalité énorme ya à 21h28 il
ya un truc vraiment qui m'a réveillé moi
c'est qu'ils ont parlé de mon plat
préféré regarde
ça va peut-être vous fâcher mais
voyez-vous le plat préféré des français
c'est le couscous à ça et et vous avez
les parisiens ne sont pas les plus gros
mangeurs de pizza d'europe c'est nous
les français je le prends comme un
exemple amusant de ce que signifie
l'interpénétration des cultures et la
production d'une culture en commun alors
j'ai regardé le sondage non le couscous
est troisième à deuxième est moins
stricte et premier le magret de canard
mais voilà c'est ça ton super maxis de
région est important de le dire mais
c'est pas un péché
[Applaudissements]
mais je trouve sa colère
réducteur de réduire la culture
orientale ou maghrébine ou couscous
tajine aux beignets un truc et voilà les
briques elle a pris la forme et ça et
moi c'est comme comme moi quand je suis
en boîte à chaque fois qu'ils ont
entendu musique genre et khaled tout le
monde tombe
juste un point c'était par rapport à
cette histoire de politique
professionnelle c'est pas une le montant
que d'être politique professionnelle
mais par contre la différence
fondamentale me semble-t-il c'est qu'il
ya un candidat qui prend un risque
gigantesque parce que dans la vie il est
assis en tant que chroniqueur en tant
que journaliste on peut l'aimer ne pas
l'aimer mais il faut dire qu'il n'a que
des coups à prendre et silva c'est
évidemment parce qu'il défend une idée
voilà ça c'est fondamentalement alors lé
2 allée doivent aider quoi êtes ancien
aujourd'hui les gens c'est son métier et
j'en ai eu de base est basé son job
c'est
salé ou le gip a réagi défavorablement
au fait d'être qualifié de deux hommes
politiques professionnels c'est parce
que vous avez ont dit les chiens
pouvaient que voilà restera et est facho
un peu souvent mais oui bah ça c'est un
de gaulle et fachos alors d'accord mais
alors après normes et de gaulle il y
avait beaucoup de choses savez vous avez
le droit de la doré sans nuances mais
c'est un personnage comme tous les
personnages politiques historiques
discute c'est bien supérieur les avions
lorsque j'ai voulu et messieurs vous
plaît restons sur le débat halal alors
moi j'ai voulu être ça bref je viens de
d'une famille de petites gens j'ai voulu
être un homme qui peut vous et famille
au combat politique c'est ce que j'ai
fait en passant si j'avais voulu être
curé je fais donné curé pour défendre la
foi catholique parce que ma famille
était catholique
j'ai voulu faire la politique égalitaire
va pour l'égalité tout ça sérieux et
j'ai fait par le parcours qui me
paraissait normal c'est à dire ouais et
me faire lire pour ça et donc être porte
parole de jean pierre aujourd'hui comme
j'ai déclaré ma candidature j'ai demandé
aux gens de parrainer enfin il y en a
250 migrants avaient des achats mais
c'est comme ça je vois la vie donc je
n'ai aucune jean-luc j'aimerais
j'aimerais voir la vidéo les deux hommes
de louis louis brouillard vous pour toi
jean luc est sorti gagnant du d'une rave
arias ou si eric zemmour vrai je suis
assez d'accord avec lui j'aime pas trop
parler de match mais par contre ce que
je vois c'est qu'il y avait un homme
politique et y avait un chroniqueur et
j'ai pas vu l'homme politique dans le
chroniqueur pour moi il n'a pas vraiment
réussi à se démarquer bossi
particulièrement sûr enfin sur les
arguments il a parlé d'immigration il a
donné des chiffres des chiffres que
j'avais beaucoup entendu même ici est en
fête appris que dedans il comptait pas
les étudiants il comptait pas les
départs donc il s'est trompé sur ces
chiffres de l'immigration des chaudières
bas j'ai appris qu'ils se trompaient
beaucoup quand il a parlé d'écologie
quand il parlait quand il parlait
d'écologie bah je me battre je
m'attendais quand même à voir a osé
moore sur quelque chose de nouveau il a
passé vingt minutes à nous parler des
éoliennes et du nucléaire sans ne rien
proposer et à la fin il a dit ma
proposition sur l'écologie c'est de
faire une écologie proche de la nature
et respectueuse des traditions mais si
on l'a pendant cinq ans on est pas dans
la merde avec zemmour alors voilà lors
il ya eu une petite embrouille sur les
prénoms vous en parliez voilà on en
parle il ya quelques jours regarder
voilà onze ans grand père est arrivé de
du d'espagne du maroc et algérie qu'est
ce qu'il a fait il s'appelait mélenchon
il a changé son nom il a francisé le
mien mon grand-père a changé de prénom
il s'est appelé justin ça c'est
l'assimilation à la française vous en
êtes le produit mais vous le renier
aujourd'hui je veux vous dire ceci les
gens s'appelle comme idole ils le font
par tradition familiale quand quelqu'un
appelle puisque c'est là dessus vous
avez cherché quelqu'un son fils mohamed
c'est souvent parce que le grand père
s'appelait comme ça et quand on donne un
prénom à un enfant c'est parce qu'on
veut le placer sous la protection de ce
prénom il n'y a pas de honte à donner le
nom vous avez raison de même qu ya pas
de honte à s'appeler david ou cueillait
des milliers de cadeaux vicieux mais
n'ont jamais le mari ne savait alors
vous êtes prête à changer de prénom
pareil on va dire bye bye à carla si
vous êtes d'accord avec lui sur les
prénoms alors moi je suis d'accord avec
lui sur les prénoms pourquoi parce que
pour moi en fait c'est comme avec la
sphère du voile c'est qu'en fait on se
stigmatisent alors je comprends
j'entends tout à fait une histoire de on
veut donner le le prénom de son
grand-père ou ou de sa grand mère je
comprends tout à fait mais c'est une
sorte en fait on crée de la
discrimination et pour moi c'est
important de respecter le pays dans
lequel on habite et le nom le nom c'est
notre histoire je mangeais mon nom ne
sera pas ne sera pas dévoilée ce soir
mais mon nom est d'origine algérienne et
j'ai un autre que j'ai pris les deux
noms j'ai le nom également de mon père
qui est un nom de consonance italienne
mais je voulais juste venir sur la
bannière à quoi magna car la voilà c'est
un prénom qui est mixte serpent c'est
vrai mais j'ai l'excusé mois série veux
juste revenir sur un point c'est que
eric zemmour ce n'est pas qu'un
éditorialiste ont un journaliste c'est
un homme de valeurs et de convictions et
c'est ça qu'on oublie c'est qu'on avait
un politicien mélenchon et on avait un
homme de valeurs et de convictions qui
fait aujourd'hui vibrer beaucoup de
français et qui redonne beaucoup
d'espoir voilà alexis vouliez dire un
mot un mot si tu perds mais déjà si on
accumule les deux émissions ça fait 6
millions de gens et ressort qui on veut
des débats moi je trouve que c'est bien
que le pays se politise et j'espère
seulement l'élection qui vient ça va
continuer à monter de niveau c'est bien
qu'on discute et là où il ya un carton
qui est utile c'est que effectué on
n'est pas obligé d'en passer par la
grande émission moi je comprends pas ce
qu'on a dit mais des bords fait dix
jours nous obtiendrons du fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens et que la politique
réintéresse exactement deuxièmement
madame pour vous répondre au delà de
vous savez mener bien eric zemmour si
vous aimez la politique tant mieux dans
certains points de vue moi je vous en
fais pas s'il vous plaît
moi j'appelle madame parce que justement
je pense que je suis quand même je
suis pas marié non mais je sais pas si
vous avez suivi mais les femmes fait moi
les femmes qui sont autour de moi aime
bien que justement elle n'appelle pas
mademoiselle sur leur âge mais à égalité
pour pas avoir ce côté là ce qu'on dit
pas les mains de moison pour les garçons
mais moi justement vous avez le droit
d'aimer eric zemmour a fait part aux
bretons et vous qui êtes une femme
intelligente pascal manière dont vous
parlez en plus vous souvenez vous êtes
jeune franchement vous suivez le débat
je l'en félicite mais vous trouvez vous
je cite eric zemmour à propos des femmes
les femmes ne crée pas elles
entretiennent elle n'invente pas elle
conserve elle ne force pas elle préserve
et c'est en se féminise ans les hommes
se stérilise ils s'interdisent à toute
audace et vous comme femme qui aimait la
politique vous pensez que les femmes
elle n'en vaut pas
vous avez envie de soutenir un homme qui
demande est présenté à un public qui
pensent que parce que vous êtes femme
vous êtes inférieures aux hommes je vous
écoute je
réponde à ça près je voudrais pas vous
donner un exemple
donnez moi le nom aujourd'hui d'une
femme qui fait de la politique qu'est
féminine elle se masculinistes ou dans
les réformes
et les femmes ne vont pas venir au lycée
marie curie est donné dans l'entente du
pain et marie curie tu voues dépressives
ou faire de la politique comment est-ce
qu'elle a inventé des choses marie curie
bien sûr d'accord donc ce que disait ni
autiste on est alors alors si on fait
non il aura traversé des mois est très
importante
explique au bout de deux heures de débat
presse pour que quelqu'un pose enfin la
question eric zemmour pour savoir si les
candidats va laisser ses jean luc
mélenchon a dit jean-luc regarder jeudi
soir ça vous plaît puisque ça c'est à
dire qu'il manque le candidat pour
incarner cela et c'est vous je ne sais
pas si c'est moi mais en tout cas il
manque le candidat pour incarner cela ça
c'est indéniable
moi je les ai connues plus direct en
vous n'avez pas nous faire le numéro à
la macro et compagnie je sais pas je
sais je sais pas mais comme anne hidalgo
pendant des mois vous permettez que je
choisis ce moment et je le comprends
mais tournons pas autour du pot moi je
n'étais pas je vous dis je choisirais
mongolien pour décider non ma copine
pour décider bah oui on verra bien si
j'oserais queen quoi attendre le moment
diront la coupe et d'ailleurs
il va être candidat pour vous
merci mais si j'aurais juste revenir sur
demande et à ses deux jeunes fils une
femme est très simple tu déchires je
sais pas je suis un bar contredire faut
pas l'offensé je voudrais il s'agit de
réfléchir à ce propos elle vit d'un côté
un homme de valeur de l'autre côté un
politicien quelle fille vous permet
madame de mépriser ma vie de cette
manière méprisé mais ça nous avait
écoutés filoche un petit peu du monde si
l'on
[Rires]
garde des sceaux française des jeux à
l'exigence on tue en silence nomme g2
décoration l'une chez l'autre argentine
pour avoir lutté contre des dictateurs
est sorti des gens de prison respectez
moi
je trouve ça et vous adversaire
jean luc jean luc da question mercredi
en tête de valeur d'un côté après des
petits chiens jean luc est ce que est ce
que ça compte de ce qu'est l'existence
d'un militant vous ne savez rien jaulin
qu'on en reparlera si tu veux mon jean
luc juste jean-luc pour toi vous êtes à
égalité dans les sondages en avril en
liant luc mélenchon vous êtes vous êtes
vous êtes égalité dans les sondages avec
zemmour est ce que vous pensez que vous
allez finir devant lui s'il se présente
avec l'enjeu de delà de la campagne
électorale mais une campagne électorale
ça veut dire des gens
l'accord celle des débats parce que vous
savez dans ce qu'on appelle ma famille
politique qui est composée pour une part
de gens particulièrement venimeux ont
passé 48 heures avant le débat a
expliqué il fallait pas aller parler
avec monsieur zemmour et c'est moi de
zemmour dont il disait du manque peu de
moi que vous voulez y aller alors c'est
pas plus compliqué pour moi que pour
d'autres parce que je dois
continuellement me bats avec une sorte
de gens qui me tire dans le dos alors
j'ai hâte mais c'est bien c'est la vie
c'est tout je la merci de la lutte
politique et voilà je profite par
exemple de ma présence sur ce plateau
pour avoir pu passer trois quatre idées
j'ai vu ça j'ai vu ça va jeter grillé
jean luc a alors et regarder très serré
un quai de bahia événement il ya eu plus
de 120000 vote qui a été meilleur
scénario adapté aux mille questions
ceinture les réseaux sont en tout cas
plus un match nul un match nul et plus
de 120 mille votes pensent que les deux
roues qui gagne enfin qu'un manuel est
faux est ce que ça a cartonné